right
welcome back everyone so in this uh
final talk of the morning vadim will
give a finally a true board talk and
will tell us about uh zero knowledge
proofs from lattices so vadim has been
doing great work on that is based crypto
and it's going to tell us about the
state of the art
okay uh yeah thanks stephanie
uh yeah so i'm giving a board talk and i
mean the reason i
i think a lot of
these tools keep getting reused i think
it's easier to keep pointing back at
them to not erase stuff than to keep
keep coming back so i don't know this
that's the theory of it
echoey okay
so okay so this talk is about a lot of
space here knowledge and it's not just
you know it's the it's not just can we
do a lot of space zero knowledge proof
sort of lattice uh pre images for a lot
of you know the width for lattice
witnesses in zero knowledge of course we
can
right i mean there's nothing special
about that the the question is can we do
it efficiently right so i mean the goal
at the end is to build privacy-based
protocols based on the hardness of
lattices and the reason we want to do
that is um
you know you have to you have to give
motivation for this because we can build
privacy-based protocols based on just
hash functions you know i mean you have
these all these great schemes like
aurora ligero whatever and that's you
know i think i'm showing my age because
he's like five years old which is a
lifetime in zero nine is probably a plus
plus in front of uh
all of them um
so and they're already quite efficient
they're even snarks so they're they're
compact
but the the point is the hope is that um
by sort of leveraging the special the
the
the algebraic structure of lattices you
can do the same thing much more
efficiently right and more compactly
this is kind of a state of the art the
same as the state of the art of digital
signatures you can get digital
signatures even quantum safe digital
signatures uh you know i think these
these were the first digital signature
they were ever invented there were
quantum safe digital signatures from
merkle trees right but with you know
specialized assumptions whether it's
where whether from lattices from you
know other stuff you can get them more
efficiently right so this is kind of the
same hope as with zero knowledge but the
interesting thing about zero knowledge
is that we i mean you know we're talking
about sort of talking about replacing
aurora ligero but we can't even do
schnaar efficiently for like we couldn't
even we can't even do schnorr kind of
efficiently pilates so forget snarks
forget compactness just you know you
have a s equals t prove that s is small
right so
so this is the kind of the general uh
thing uh you have some matrix a
you know let's say mod q
um i'm not going to write mod too much
uh and then prove that
groove knowledge
of s
and norm of s is small
right so can we even do that right so
you would think that the the very first
thing you should be able to do you know
if you talk about zero knowledge is to
prove the basic one-way function
knowledge of basic memory function right
and even this we cannot do we could not
do efficiently i mean of course you
could do it and you know the best
schemes were kind of they took a couple
of megabytes to prove the basic thing
but this is not acceptable right because
i don't know aurora aguero i mean they
can do it in a few hundred kilobytes
they can do anything in a few hundred
kilobytes right
so so then i i think it's a very good
question as to why why is it so hard for
discrete lag it's very easy this
protocol existed for a while it's schnar
so what is the difficulty with lattices
and i think the fundamental difficulty
is
well it's the small part right and
because when you say small that's a
range proof and if you know things about
range proofs they're not trivial to get
base you know usually the most efficient
ones have these
yeah a short and fat tall and skinny
the
um
what is a uh well it's uh it's
not not tall right it makes the problem
hard otherwise okay there's no error i'm
never going to write an error this is
lwe you know if you want error put an
identity in a yes
yeah i mean it's it's this
kind of doesn't matter
okay
so so the hard part is the small right
because it's a range proof and range
groups are not easy right so now we're
kind of so that the goal of this whole
line of research is to get range proofs
for you know from lattices and i think
in the last couple of years we really
went down from like two megabytes
for the most basic thing and now we're
down to really 10 kilobytes or something
like that so and it's um
so what i want to just talk about today
is just a kind of a toolbox for um
what uh for how how did how to do these
things and it turns out it's actually
quite simple so if you kind of i don't
know walk away from the talk thinking
the whole uh
all the people are incompetent in this
research area i think that's
i think i will have done my job
so yeah because it really is the toolbox
is quite
um it's quite small
yeah
uh
can can you remind us what legero is
like what what does it what does it do
is it is
square root such uh you know uh are you
the square root yeah square to sync
doesn't even matter right but the point
is that it's
it's based on general assumptions it's
based on hash functions right and uh so
there's always a target to be you can't
just say in a public key encryption you
say i have a lot of space encryption
scheme well you know deal with it right
whereas here you know you have to say no
look how does it compare to the generic
source
right so you don't you don't want to
make violence assumptions unless they
are useful first of course right
and the way you would use ligero here is
write down the verification circuit
and exactly just commit to s using some
hash function and prove that as i know
the communication assets and this is
what we're going to do for lattice as
well we're going to commit to s and then
prove that s satisfies this
yeah so
the question is exactly so what are the
rules of the game you're playing right
so because you can compile it as an
empty statement then you'll shoot system
but you want to have something more
latino no the right no there's there are
no rules to this game right so it's not
that we're saying no the gyro is out you
know because
no the rule is you want to minimize the
proof's efficiency that's it they're
just a proof sense right proof sites and
here i'm just talking about i'm going to
talk about just linear groups so not
nothing compact so even that was hard
but compact you know that will and you
first have to get later so that's what
david the proof size comes with
corresponding improvement to the running
time
right now everything is is linear or
linear rate of quasi-linear in terms of
the
uh witnesses
so there's even even that was a hard uh
i i mean linear you know you can always
define efficient you know you can always
redefine efficiency right complete
efficiency it's not that you pay any
price if you make the troops uh as
shortly as possible
but it's not like it's making the total
worth harder or something
um
i mean maybe it's you know maybe some
factor small factor harder but
but it is uh there's no there's no
there's no trades there are not really
there's nothing bad that will happen i'm
pretty sure it's going to be extremely
efficient we have implemented versions
of this and this is kind of along those
lines it shouldn't be
so um
yeah so since i don't have slides if you
want to go you know kind of get you know
you want to
kind of
get some matino background material for
this talk i'm kind of summarizing this
um the introduction to our paper
which is uh
so it's so it's an eprint 2000 so it's a
crypto but it's an eprint like 2022 284
uh eprint
if you want to kind of get the slides or
there is some written material for it
it's this all right so it's a it's joint
work with my students uh kang guin and
maxim klenson
and but it's actually based on work that
was done you know
by you know before as well so all the
references you can get in the in that
paper
okay so let's let's first you know
should we want to try to do schnar let's
see what happens if we try to do schnoor
okay
and um so i'm going to say that we're
going to prove this this equation we're
trying to prove i want to prove it you
know i want to be able to prove it i
don't care if it's over z over or some
polynomial ring uh this doesn't matter
but we are going to want to like i kind
of hinted we're going to want to commit
to s and then prove this relation and
the commitments are going to be more
most efficient in polynomial rings
and so i'm going to kind of define this
ring
our q forever you know for the remainder
of the talk it'll be sort of this ring
zqx mod x the d plus one
where d is the some dimension so this
will be you know we will be you basing
everything on module lwe
um and we'll kind of we'll get into it
once once the thing starts we'll uh
we'll we'll know what module lw is
okay so i mean if you've heard of regal
we this is kind of the same thing except
we don't except the rings are smaller
and there's you know more of them
um
but anyway yeah so we'll get into that
doesn't really matter so this d uh again
i will try to motivate why we set
everything the way we do
but i i do want to kind of hint that
module lw is really the right problem to
use it's not for if for security it's
it's really the um kind of
the right thing to do and hopefully you
will see why okay
so
so let's say we have a s equals t mod q
and everything is over this rig all the
elements in a are over this ring
okay
and if you have questions just ask
anyone okay
what's the value of d so typically uh so
we'll see what it should but typically
it'll be you know 64 128.
sorry
um
so let's say q will be about you know
say 2 to the 16 to the 32 and d will be
about 64.
okay
and so we have the matrix a that's all
you know okay so here's the a
okay i use a different
color
so here's your a
and it's uh you know it's this n by m
matrix
and the hardness of the you know this
the dimension integer dimension is d
times n and d times f right it's kind of
the hardness of this this problem
depends on them
okay
all right good
so so let's just try to do a basic
protocol to try to prove this to prove
that we know a small s
you know
so let's do
okay
so we pick some y some masking parameter
y from some distribution
make it small then compute w equals a y
uh what
okay
so then we send w
the verifier sensor approver this is the
verifier
uh picks a challenge c
from some challenge sets and c i will
kind of try to define
a little bit what these are compute z
equals s c plus y
and then the the homomorphic relation
that's going to be satisfied is a z
equals t c plus
so if you've seen schnar this is
right but there are some some things
that uh there are different lattices
in schnorr
y is uniformly random
so y completely masks says c for lattice
says that's not really interesting
because you want z to be small
right so the whole hardness of lattice
is the smallness right so some something
has to be small so
you know if y is not
big a y is not uniform then it doesn't
quite mask s times c
so that's a problem that could leak s
um
so you have to do some rejection
sampling here and i'm not going to talk
about this because this is pretty old
already
um so you have to kind of do look at you
do some rejection something to make sure
that the distribution of z is going to
be uniform and distribution of s
is going to be independent of
distribution okay i'm not going to
there's this is
let's say sort of standard right now
um
and so
now the c
right
you want the chat you want the challenge
space to be big
right
so this is kind of why we want this ring
to be somewhat big so what we want is we
want
the challenge space to be big but at the
same time z to have small norm
right so if we are if if c is an integer
well you can't really have that many
small integers
right so that's why it's nicer to have
c be a polynomial and then
you know you have a lot of small
binomials if it's polynomial degree 64
well there's you know 264 01 polynomials
neither do you want c to be large to
avoid parallel repetition or uh i
wouldn't be right i want the right the
size of the challenge space to be big so
you don't do in europe so you have
soundness but i also want the norm of c
to be small so that you have z be small
okay
it's just the
normal coefficient yeah
the rejection something it's like start
over or if if you reject you have to
start over and it's not a problem to
reveal you with jeff it's not a problem
okay so this is a good question right so
um
in an interactive protocol
uh you can prove that if you don't
reject
right then actually the distribution is
perfect right in an interactive in a
if you do reject then not quite so you
have what you so there's two answers to
this one is you can easily make
everything zero knowledge by hashing the
w
but actually you don't care because i
don't even care about interactive
protocols i care about non-interactive
protocols and there you never really
reject reveal that you're rejected
because you just keep doing it until you
mean
it doesn't matter that it doesn't matter
because you never see any rejected
transfers
but yeah this is something that i'm not
but yeah sure you cannot you should you
should ask questions about uh
this stuff as well but i'm kind of not
covering even how to do the rejection
sampling what's the most efficient way
to do it
okay
so
now um so what does this really prove
right what would we end up proving
um so the way you yeah
i'm sorry no c is not c is a subset of
our q that has small coefficients okay
css
and then what is the computation for z
vector so you multiply a polynomial
vector times c
so that is what happens over q
everything happens over
but you know there's no reduction but q
here because they're all very small s
small c small ones
so it is also uh element team a is also
referential yeah everything is
so good so now um
what does this prove right why does this
not prove this you know for schnorr it
proves what we want here it does not
well it's because so let's just do the
basic thing let's do um
um
let's do rewinding right let's extract
something so okay so this
i see
z right so he rewinds c prime z prime
and we know that a z equals t c plus w
and a z prime equals t c prime plus o
right and norm of z
and norm of z prime
okay so from here what he gets is he
gets a times z minus z prime
equals t times
c minus c prime and i'm just going to
rewrite this as like a times z
equals t
okay
so
this is what we extract
so in schnorr
so when something like this happens you
just divide by
c here not so much right once you divide
by c now things are not small anymore
right but it's okay right because you do
prove this
and so so basically knowing an s
satisfying a s equals t you end up
proving as a small z which is not as
small as s anymore
right because we multiplied by c we
added some y so now it's bigger and
there's the c that's appearing it's
small but it's still not what we want
not we kind of what we know we know
something more but we can only prove
this okay
yeah you would use this to prove to mp
as your knowledge for mp somehow right
so this is this will be yeah i mean this
is kind of what we're building right
this will be good enough for so this is
not what we want but eventually but this
is all we know how to do so we will use
this to build what we want okay
all
having this right
prove that you know s
even more basic level yeah
so all i proved is that i know a z
and a c satisfying this equation oh okay
that's all i proved
right so this is not what we want right
if i
know so what i'm building at you know
this talk is to prove this so far we
have this right okay but you should
believe that this is still hard right if
i give you a and t it's still hard to
come up with a z and a c
satisfying this this is as hard as cis
you have some somewhat
easier version of system i mean the
proof is simple right i mean you think
if i know a and a t so i can basically
set up
a and a s equals t
right
the the whatever the solver gives me a z
and a c
so a z
equals
t c
right and i just plug in the s in here
and so from this i end up with a z
minus
s c
equals zero right
and so i have a solution for cis you
have to be a little careful this can't
be zero right so why can't this be zero
or at least why isn't it zero
to one
to one right i think my s so that
there's many s's that that you know
there's just to be at least two right i
just pick it so there's two and then
with probabilities to have this will not
be
okay
so this is still a hard problem and this
is basically used as um
as the basis for signature for signature
schemes for example right so i just
proved to do it i do this
right and the the hash
in the theatre mirror the message goes
into the hash and this is a signature
scheme you can forge you can solve this
problem which was hardest
okay so for signatures this is all we
need but
this is not quite good enough for other
things for example
um
this equation could also be an
encryption right like the regular
encryption has this
form a s equals t right so if i want to
prove to you
that uh i encrypted correctly
this doesn't quite prove that right
because you know i say look i encrypted
correctly well not really right you
maybe you multiply it by c
and now the decryptor can't even decrypt
right so that's that's one of these
applications uh that you sometimes want
right you want to prove that hey you
know anyone can do something the guy
with the secret key can decrypt but he
cannot because there's a c here yeah is
it clear there's actually like an attack
like that it suffices just to know how
to do this weaker thing like it's not
clear to me how to do this weaker thing
without or how to uh uh
how to actually run the protocol
successfully without having to actually
prove successfully without actually
going why not
um no so this is a good this is a good
question right i mean for example i
it's i mean you could come up with
artificial waves right i could give you
for example
um
let's say i know i'm hoping that c is a
factor of uh
something but that's not a reasonable
hope but let's say i i give you an s
where s is perturbed a little bit and
only sometimes you know how to
but but there's a there's a
so i see what you're so noah's question
is
but really you know if you do this
surely you know the s right that's kind
of what it's like law and the definition
of proof of knowledge as well but isn't
that sure
so so no no so i don't think that's
that's even it but even if that is
correct which i don't think it is uh
which it's not but but uh no the point
the point is this that's not good enough
because like i'm going back to my uh
encryption example right let's say i
encrypt something i want to prove that i
encrypted correctly which somehow it
implies that you can decrypt right
okay but i could be cheating right i
could have uh you know divided my
s by like uh you know x minus one for
example all right and then i'm hoping
that the c you get will be a factor of x
minus one then i divide up and and the
point is even though
yes i know the s
right
it's not a valid encryption anymore
right so basically i cheated in the kind
of
the statement is false
right and that usually you want the
statement to be true for applications
right otherwise it's kind of pointless
okay
all right
so
yeah so this is a this is a literal
translation of or
right trying to prove something about it
is there a
different way
it's a multiplicative way or something
so instead of additively translating s
right
uh multiply s by uh rotate us randomly
rotate this let's say
i mean like an automorphism i mean we've
thought about all these things yeah and
that's i mean the group is additive
right so it's not
there's this the homomorphism is this
way so
and you also want your uh
the challenge space to be big i mean
we've thought about you know if this is
this is what took this is what took
decades but there's really i mean there
is a simple there is the the strategy is
you use this
and then you you commit you can create
commitments that's the next thing i
would say you can create a commitment
scheme from this
and then you commit and then you can
prove stuff about the committedness so
this is the
this will be the thing okay
so
so kind of the
the the what i'm gonna
do the
is the outline is so you prove a z
equals c t right so we have this
that's all we know how to do
so from this we can get a commitment
scheme
with a proof of opening with a proof of
opening
and then you can do
you can prove linear relations
over our q
so in the commitment scheme i can prove
to you that that my you know
the committed values satisfy some with
some relation of our cube now the
interesting part so this is not super
interesting easy the interesting part
starts in this step now i can prove
linear relations
over z cubed
zero so all this is zero now so when i
say prove it proven zero knowledge okay
so this kind of because now now
something is happening
and once and then even more interest
well somewhat interestingly you can
prove linear relations
over z
so not mod q anymore
so why is going from rq to zq
the
the harder the interesting part well
it's not super hard but it's not
it's not uh
so you think it should be trivial
because you can embed cq inside uh
inside our cube and you don't want to
read you don't want to reveal the other
parts right you don't want to reveal the
other parts
and you want to prove
yeah so we will be embedding
and so so none of this is going to
become so in retrospect this is all yeah
this is all going to be
so yeah it's pretty simple but
um
yeah i mean we will want to embed
relations in ezekiel rq and then hide
all the irrelevant hide all the other
parts
it's not hard but it has to be okay um
and um
so then kind of using very similar
technique well
kind of over here we're gonna do proof
quadratic relations
relations
over
rq
this the kind of the same techniques
will be proving
quadratic relations
over z
over z cubed
this will be the same same idea
once you have this and this idea it's
the same thing
and then you can prove
a
quadratic relations
over z
and then once you can prove quadratic
relations over z now you have norm right
squared norm okay but you can actually
you can get exact norm here here i'm
going to show you can get approximate
norm as well
um
so you can get rid of this c but the z
will still be bigger than the s so kind
of in this step we will prove
given knowing a s equals t i can prove
that i know
a times a bigger s equals t
and once i have this then i can prove to
you that i actually know the s of the
exact norm that i
right
but also once you go to the right hand
side column
you are in nb land right yeah here you
can do yes yes
but again efficiency
efficiently
so just a bunch of tricks too this is
more than sort of getting to the right
hand side column
writing down the the verification
equation here as a degree two polynomial
and then applying it
is it
basically yeah it's it's gonna be done
so
i'm going to do a small rewriting
okay so basically uh so if you have a s
equals t we have a s equals t i'm going
to prove
so we can prove you know like i said az
equals tc
but i'm going to rewrite this this is
equivalent
to say i know a v
and a c
such that
av equals t
norm of c is small
and
bc
is just
it's the same thing it's just more
convenient to do do you see how
it's really just a pure awake type
question
so
knowing a small z and z bar and c bar
satisfying this is equivalent to knowing
of v and the c satisfying this
what
yes
oh i mean it's it's it's easy but but
there's one a little issue
z equals bc yeah z equals
vc yeah but not all these are
for b times c right
so no i i'm not going up and down
yeah let's just let's just go this way
yeah but but wait there's a so yeah so
okay so
v equals z over c right
z bar receiver but this requires that
c bar isn't vertical
okay so we need to kind of assume that
that and the c bar remember was the
difference of these two c's we have to
kind of assume that's you know the
difference is invertible which is not
always true but we can always set it up
to be this way and we don't pay any any
price okay
you just take q to be a prime such that
you this no no so i mean you're going to
say you want this to be a field this is
never a few
except for d equals two yeah
actually yeah this is never a field the
best you can do is splits into two uh d
over two parts but it's okay because you
can prove that uh small elements are
invertible so i guess you pick a random
small element right
then you have a set of very large set of
other guides that you subtract from it
that makes the difference invertible is
that uh
because so for example i mean this this
is this could be easily false if uh you
know this splits completely right
response to this completely then the
probability one over q this is simply
this will be non-invertible
well what i if you think cnc trying to
run to be random small independent brand
and small potentially yeah but that's
what the prover can wait for right he
can wait for c's that are
that he can sort of choose which c's he
answers okay
you need to be investors
[Music]
um it would be it's fine if it's with
high probability of random seeds but
and we thought we needed that because we
thought we wanted things to split now we
don't care so we can really set it up we
can pick a q
uh that i think equals five minute three
mod a and then it's it's all the small
elements are inverted
when q is uh
five eight or three my eight i forget
which one
then all small elements are
and that's fitting
okay
all right so now as i'm sort of getting
we're going to build the commitment
scheme
and um so i'm going to prove that
uh for
80
if there exists
two set two
valid
uh vv prime
satisfying
you know
one two and three
then we can break this
this is broken for a
okay so a is always going to be some
random uh you know common random thing
so cis is broken for me
okay so this is also not so hard to see
right so suppose we have
a times b equals t
and a times v prime equals t
right we have this and you know these
c's exist right so c and c prime exist
so do you see what what happens right we
just then this implies that
a times v c c prime minus v prime c c
prime equals zero right just by
multiplying
by c c prime on both sides subtracting
right
and then you end up with this
well
this
is small
this
is small
right a small norm that's by this
assumption
and now multiplying by c prime and c is
also small
that's by this assumption
right so this guy is small
and it's not zero because
these are invertible and v and v prime
are
are not the same
okay so something i missed uh yeah
probably crucial right b is not small
now b is not small b is z divided by c
yeah if b were small then we'd be done
with this right but v is not small
all right good so we have these um
these things
so just something to to remember
until the next
thing so now we have commitments and
commitments we also already know so so
far that everything is is simple i'm
just sort of setting it up
for what's going to happen all right so
now we have the ite commitment
and this is uh
basically when i type invented cis it's
immediately a commitment okay so you
have a message s one
this one and it has small norms
so to commit to
s
you pick randomness
s2 small norm
and output a times a1 s1 plus a2 s2
equals t
okay so that's that's the commitment to
this okay i think everyone has seen this
okay
and now i want to give a proof of now
now some of the interesting thing is
that we're going to be giving proofs of
knowledge of all things right so i'm
going to prove so i'm going to give a
proof of knowledge that i know an
opening to s1
okay
and so all i do is this right that's the
protocol this is the only protocol we
know so we're going to use this protocol
right
so we're going to end up proving
right so if i so the a is like
you know combined i mean
a
is a1 a2
and the s is
s1
[Music]
test
and then i run this
okay this is a bit yeah okay so what are
we going to end up proving from from
this
right we're going to prove that we know
a1 b1 plus a2 b2 equals tc
sorry equals t
right and then there's some c there also
exists a c satisfying that c is small
and this time c is small this time c
small
okay
and
by this lemma
these guys are unique
okay there's no second opening
okay
therefore this is the message
right that's my message
why is v1v2 unique sorry why why do you
have uniqueness it's professionally
right okay
okay
so
it's binding and the hiding part comes
from the fact that a2s2 is put around
so that's it this is the itai commitment
with an opening
okay and now what if i want to prove a
linear relation over our q
right let's say i want to prove that
let's suppose uh
we have r times s1 plus r equals zero
this is this i want to prove that this
is satisfied so with this commitment
it's trivial as well so you just write
so then you have these equations are
satisfied so you have a 1 s1 plus
a2
s2 equals
t and also uh
bar zero
yep
so this is the equation that
you're satisfied so all you do is you
set up this
and then you end up proving
this one and this implies that this
linear relation over our q holds
so nothing really happened
and the important thing is that it
actually the proof size is the same
because the proof size only
depends on the you know size of s1 so it
doesn't depend on how how tall this
matrix is it just depends
but of course you do more work but
good
all right so uh now just a small thing
um
the italian commitment is great it's
fine uh it's actually really good
because the you know if the s1 is really
tall it's really big the commitment is
still small so kind of the commitment
size does not depend on the message
size which is good but the norm of s1
has to be small
right so so we also want to be able to
we want a slightly different commitment
um that can commit to
bigger messages right to sort of message
their arbitrary
right
so this is like the
also kind of simple this bdlp commitment
so there to commit to m
we would write a
uh
b
r plus
0 m
equals
now r is small this is the randomness
all right
good
so uh an m can be arbitrary and the way
you prove that you know m
is you just prove you know r because you
once you know the r determines the m
okay because m is just t b minus v o
so once and the r is going to be unique
by that
so
nothing is happening it's just now we
have a way to commit to him and it's um
so binding by cis
hiding by the fact that this
looks random
and
you can also
kind of do the obvious thing
let me erase it because who chooses
those factors
these are random
aes chooses them it's a yes of one you
know
it's a css it's yours but yeah sure
but yeah
it exists i mean these these things are
not important in practice
it's yeah it's just
okay and so now we can actually combine
these two commitments into
one um
because they each have like nice parts
and one commitment you can commit to um
um
uh arbitrary sized messages and the
other commitment you can commit to
arbitrary long messages but we can
combine the two of them into one
and you know
we called it abdlop
and this is just so you have matrices
a1
so basically
s2 is the randomness
randomness
and s1 and m are the messages
okay so without this part
this is the bdlop commitment without the
bottom row it's the high tide
so you can commit to s1 and m kind of so
when you want to commit to arbitrary
size measures you put them in here when
you want to commit to small but long
messages you put them with you
you think i could find multiple things
yeah and it saves you something because
you don't have this top part twice
right i can
it's a yeah
it looks like a rag of encryption except
you know m is arbitrary size so it's
kind of maybe
maybe gsw
shai says it's kind of a gsw
but i don't know but yeah this is a
you can think of it for certain values
of b and for a certain degree decryption
thing it's uh
but again m is arbitrary so that takes a
little bit for gsw you'd have to
multiply m and like root q times m or
something like that right okay
um yeah and so for this you can also
prove arbitrary uh over rq
uh linear relations over our q so for
example we want to prove r1 s1 plus rm
uh times m plus r equals zero
i can i can do that here as well so the
way i would do it is i would put the uh
negative r1 here
i would put the rm here
and then this part actually let me not
do this
i will prove that
a1 are negative r1
s1 plus
a2
rmb
equals ta and
not import i mean if you understood the
eye type thing
this is the same this is just you have
to work it out and you will get if you
can prove
knowledge of s1 and s2 then you prove
that
s1 and m satisfy this
satisfy this relationship
okay but it's just just nothing
interesting
okay
all right
so we're basically we basically are did
this so now something interesting is
going to happen with this right
okay so this this we knew i mean or
something like this was known for a
while okay
so so now what's the problem like what
if i want to prove a linear relation
over zq right like we not suggested well
you can kind of embed some probably
embed some operations rq but the problem
is that if i prove an operation over our
q right then i will be and i'll end up
proving quite a bit more uh than just eq
because somehow the embedding will
reveal more because you also you've got
to prove some product of polynomials but
that's going to reveal something else
okay so here's a
here's a fact
so suppose we want to we want to do an
inner product of r and s
so now i'm going to define polynomials
yep
mean you want to prove some value
about ezekiel right
yeah thank you
in the constant term of our kill
the q in the count but so where do you
get the the rnds
uh they're just gonna be gonna be in the
constant term of different polynomials
ah so now i have n different polynomials
oh that's terrible right that's the
efficiency yeah yeah
right now you just lost the fact that
now you didn't have any number of
binomials time
yeah yeah so that's the basic answer
it's terrible
um okay
let's uh
all right
so let's say i define it define so now
given like two vectors r and s i'm gonna
define polynomials are in this okay and
now what i claim is that
this inner product
is the constant coefficient of our
samplex
knowing this is not a titan yeah you
like you wrote them in different orders
intentionally
the the coefficients are decreasing
yeah this would be a weird random
mistake to make this was quite essential
uh yeah yeah so
and so so now the claim is that the
constant coefficient of this product is
the inner product
okay so i'm embedding the coefficients
you know i'm sort of using all the
polynomials but just in the end result
here okay so is it something you believe
or
or do you want to that's called right
it's a
it's a convolution but there's a
negative sign so that's why there's
that's
just x to the d plus one right
but you can do something you can do some
some linear relate some linear thing for
any for almost any range
okay
all right so the constant coefficient
here is okay okay so great so now
proving linear functions over z
is the same as proving the knowledge of
a constant coefficient over r
so we can forget about this and just say
i want to prove the null of a constant
coefficient okay
so
um
okay
so let's say the prover knows
knows
an m
such that and i'm gonna use this
notation
uh to mean the constant coefficient
okay so there's some function over m
right some um
polynomial
function over r q now remember we don't
care about
zq anymore we couldn't care about rq but
just a constant coefficient so he knows
an m such that the constant coefficient
of a linear function is zero
right so this is the most general thing
and now what i do is i want to prove
that i don't right okay
so i create a commitment
i commit to m
and
some garbage term g
okay it will be defined later and the
point of g is to mask all the
coefficients except the constant one so
g is going to be uniform
except it's going to be 0 in the
constant coefficient so g
in our q
is uniform
except
zero except you know let's use the
notation g equals zero
so then the the protocol will go like
this i send you c the commitment
the verifier
takes a gamma
in zq
picks a random gamma icq
sends the gamma
and what i would do as i pick is i send
in the z equals gamma times f of m
plus g
okay so
what keep
a proof that i actually did this
correctly
right notice that this is a linear
function
in m and g
and the proof that z
so now i have a linear function over rq
so i can use my my proof
over rq
that this equation is satisfied on the
commitment of energy
so he verifies the proof
and checks
that's the constant that the constant
coefficient of z is
okay so
barely yeah what if i choose g
maliciously what if i choose g to not
yeah it is a non-what if i choose g that
doesn't have constant term zero then
well that's what the challenge is for
right
so this gamma right if if g does not
have a constant term zero
right so the point of this is that if
the
if this is not zero if f of m is not
zero then for any g constant coefficient
of g this is not going to be zero except
the probability one over q
right so now we just we have sum this
one over q
for
basically proving um
this guy okay
so but we have sum this one over q not
and q is not so big
but it's okay we can commit to many of
these g's and have a bunch of gammas and
do this
another thing is very importantly if we
have many functions f right the size of
the proof will not go up if we have many
functions up f we just come up with many
gammas and just do a linear combination
of them right there with many
coefficients is that what you would do
what you're saying yeah so if we have
many functions f
so if we have m such that f of i of m is
zero right then he would put
gamma one through a no gamma okay
right right and they would be sum of
gamma i f i of m plus g
right if any of them is non-zero then
only with probability one over q will
you be able to get zero
right so this is actually quite
important because we don't want that
because we
in going here
we're going to uh we're going to prove
we're going to be proving quite a few uh
linear equations
okay so i think i won't have time for
this but
maybe i'll just finish off this
do this isn't your soundness error still
one over q yeah but now i'm putting many
functions
yeah i'll have to do this like i'll have
to to increase soundness i will have to
have a few g's like maybe you know four
g's or
right
but to prove many functions at once the
proof doesn't go doesn't exist
you're good yeah amortize not good but
yeah to increase sounds and this
actually gets me back to why we want to
use module lw
right so remember i said we want we want
to pick d to be fairly small
right so we wanted to be big enough to
have a good challenge space
but not too big and the reason is
because when we commit to these extra
garbage terms they go in they are
polynomials we only care about the
constant coefficient but that we have to
commit to a polynomial and this
increases the size of our um
you know even of z right z is as a
polynomial so the bigger the polynomial
is just the waste we only care about the
constant coefficient right so you want
to have as small as possible that fits a
good enough big enough challenge space
so this is why modular lovely is really
the right problem to use
okay
all right
so now we're here
okay
so now proving that relationships
yeah so if your back size is large
enough you know
if your batch size batch uh the the
you're improving many statements yeah
is as large as the wrinkle two wee
dimension then you might as well use
ring of the beauty right uh as opposed
to module
is it
no no because
the size of the ring yeah
this t yeah is going to be
is going to affect the z
this z is an element in here
so you don't want it to be too large
right
i don't want it to be too small either
because of the charge basis right
c
okay
okay
so the right answer is like 64.
this is the
okay
um next now let's try and prove many
relations over z right because once we
have this we can actually have something
interesting and okay i won't show you
how to do quadratic relations
um
but that's actually not so difficult
it's
uh all right so
facts
all right if
let's say i have let's say i have two
just vectors
uh you know vector s so a vector s
um
over
z q to the or d
um then an r is chosen from the
following distribution
so it's chosen from it's like negative
one zero one well let's say zero one
doesn't matter with probability of half
each so r is shown from zero one to the
d
okay
if
norm of s
is large
then probability
over r
r s mod q
is large
is greater than one
so basically if there if s has some
large coefficient
it's not you can't kill it off with
with it will
this is a fairly easy thing to show okay
so now the idea
for proving
this is fairly should be fairly
straightforward given what we know right
all we have to all that all the verifier
has to do is give you a bunch of r's
and you somehow have to
give him r times s
prove that you actually did r times s
correctly
we know how to do that because that's we
know how to do relations over zq and we
know how to advertise them so that's
important because you don't have one
half
and so that will prove but there's a bit
of a small small issue
um
it reveals us right
okay so the idea is kind of like this
now
right what you want to do
is you want to pick a y
from some distribution
right commit to so you want to commit to
so you have a commitment to s
now you pick some y from this
distribution and a bunch of garbage
terms
right that you need for this you have
this commitment
and then the verify so you send this to
him the verifier
sends you
a bunch of vectors r
are 128 if you want 128 bit security
right
and what you do is let's call this r so
he sends you a
matrix matrix r you send them r s
plus y
and you do rejection sam
right
so
you need a slight uh generalization of
this it's probability rs
plus y for all y
you can also prove probability of
this is large is bigger than one-half if
s is large so there's no y that can mask
this s r is random module right sorry r
is random r is zero one
okay
so then basically what he checks is that
he checks that z is small he check we
give him the proof that everything is
done correctly he checks the z smokey
checks that um
the proof works out
and now he's convinced that
that
s
was small
right because we proved to him the
reaction z really is r times s plus one
you have to choose y to be like small
but not too small exactly it's the same
exactly the same things
as over here right
would be small but not too small
um
and so now what this proves
is something better than we could get
here we basically prove that we know and
ah okay so now we haven't done the kind
of the main thing and if you in addition
want to prove this well that's just
another linear equation
it's just another set of linear
equations
so you also can prove that s satisfies
this
okay so now you've just proved that s is
small s satisfies this
and kind of that's it right so you end
up proving that a times
something that's bigger than your
original s because of this
is
t but we got rid of the c
okay
um
and um
so the whole thing you you just used uh
the ability to prove linear relations
over the quadratic we haven't we haven't
seen it yet but once you see that once
you can do quadratic right
uh so actually the quadratic there's not
much i mean it's just kind of oh no
this was this was known before once you
can do quadratic you can you can see
that you can prove the number right you
can prove the norm of s very small but
you're proving that the norm of s is
small mod q
which is not really the same as the norm
is small
right so what you have to do then
is
prove that you know so you end up
proving that normal you can prove with
the quadratic that the norm of s squared
is like some b
okay one cube
but you know you could have had a
wraparound
so what you have to prove
is an approximate
you have to prove this part first
right so if you prove that hey actually
s is small you will not get a wrap
around
okay and the norm of s squared is b
mod q well that there's no wrap around
so that means norm of s really is b so
basically you use an approximate proof
to show there's no wrap around and then
you prove relations modules
okay so this is the this is the strategy
for
this and yeah of course once how to do
this
um this is there's a somewhat nice part
of the fact that this multiplication
this this uh you know what noah said i
wrote in backward order it's actually an
automorphism in this ring
so in some sense um you will not have to
send both
okay because i'm gonna you know if i
want s i want to send
commit to s and commit to if i want to
do the product and commit to s and
commit to this automorphism of s but
because it's an automorphism i don't
have to commit to it he can compute it
himself
right so this is like a nice part to
save you another sort of small factor in
the thing but otherwise you could use
any ring and just commit to us and
commit to the weird permutation of us
whatever weird permutations has to be
and then just prove that you did the
permutation correct
okay so this is kind of so the the kind
of takeaway is the way to do commit and
prove protocols is
you have your commitments you commit
using this commitment scheme
you can prove uh you have to use the
fact that uh polynomial products
and the first course appropriate
polynomial products give you vector
products give vector inner products
then very importantly um
you can prove approx you can prove that
s is kind of small using this
right and actually like in the l2 norm
it's it's even nicer because you can get
a really tight bound using the johnson
linden strauss but it sort of doesn't
matter so much
for this high level thing
and then once you know that s is small
you can prove
relation to mod q
and that implies uh quadratic relations
of result
of zq implies
so that's the high level thing and then
with this you basically get
yeah you get proofs that are fairly
small there are only
between 10 and 10 and 20 kilobytes from
for many useful things like proof of uh
correct encryption you can get ring
signatures you can get one or many
proofs you can get all this linear
linear linear
space groups you can get
only a little bit more expensive than
the just the commitment just just having
a commitment and proving you know the
operator commitment all thanks to the
fact that all these garbage terms you
know are
that have the mask stuff are actually
small because they live in this small
way
okay so this is quite kind of important
instead of in regularly this d would be
you know a thousand or two thousand
whereas modular will be it's really just
64.
okay so that really is the right problem
to use
and
i guess
not much else
so we have a shorter lunch break
if you wanted to batch proofs of
correctness of many commitments right uh
uh that many encryptions are zero or
whatever you know um
with the proof size that is independent
of the
batch size
so so the question but the commitment
would grow right so if you don't count
the commitment size
um no so i guess by definition you would
have to come up with a shrinking
commitment
but you said their encryptions right so
if they're encryptions you probably
can't shrink
no no uh i don't know what i mean the
statements are there are end statements
we can't do anything about it
there are n witnesses too they're there
too
but somehow i could
you know
so this is uh yeah this is
what you want to start
right from minuses and it's not a snark
really it's a it's a batch uh it's a
batch argument
okay okay so here's something you can do
let's not but i mean a snark would solve
that um so here's something you can
right let's say i have a times s1 equals
t1
a times sk equals
okay
i can prove to you
in a fairly short
thing that a times that for all i
a times
uh you know this
zi equals t times
right this i can do it sure well that's
great so with proof length independent
of k right uh
yeah i mean
the
if k is not too big it grows linear
the coefficients grow linearly
okay so but this is that's something
that's already known right but this is
not quite what we know we don't we can't
i wasn't knowing how to get rid of this
it wasn't yeah but this this so this is
something you can do
um
yeah so so it's not quite a but i think
a snark would solve this uh
i know but you know
um yeah okay okay so i think one should
aim towards
this and this yeah
and the way you do this is very simple
you just uh do a sum of s i see us here
plus one right
thanks
starting live streams